good morning belief nation today's
message is get constructive feedback
over to you Brendon Burchard you need to
get in a community where you can get
feedback you need either a coach who can
give you some direct one-to-one feedback
or community of friends who just go out
with maybe you go to lunch to them once
a month you share everything you're
doing they give you some feedback or you
shoot a video you send that video out to
everybody get some feedback on it you
create a port by the PowerPoint
practice it with five people before the
big meeting like get back in the game we
have a community of people who are
giving you advanced feedback before you
release it feedback before you do it so
that you get smarter at all of this
because you know nothing makes a dream
come more into life than when you start
getting feedback from other people about
your movement toward the dreams you know
before I shoot a big sales video for one
of my online courses I'll send it out to
15 20 people and get feedback and then
off and go reshoot it again you know or
I'll put it out into my community and
I'll see the clicks the conversions and
say it's not let's do it again
and it's that willingness to get
feedback that will keep your dream alive
because look if it's just in your mind
and you just doing it by yourself but
you never actually get a positive
community giving you constructive
feedback towards it it will never be
that but that it will never be in the
social realm and when it is in the
social realm it feels more real you know
when people are actually comment I mean
it's one thing to be in an artist and in
your studio painting for yourself all
day that's great but once you get some
feedback on it and constructive feedback
you become you get that self-awareness
and that social awareness to contribute
and create at another level
I love this message because I think a
lot of entrepreneurs we create in a
vacuum we don't get enough feedback on
what we're doing and we're not the best
at everything and so there's a lot of
holes in your ideas and your plans in
your execution and if you don't talk to
other people about how you can fix
and you can't afford to hire a team yet
then your business suffers one of the
things I found really helpful is I
started a mastermind group here in
Toronto for entrepreneurs and we meet
every month and we get together we talk
about the businesses and try to help
each other out I started that base off
in Napoleon's Hills books Think and Grow
Rich where we talked about mastermind
groups I think it's something that's
extremely valuable I think a lot of
entrepreneurs don't have enough other
entrepreneurial friends that they can
connect with and share experiences with
and so it highly encourage you if you
can find one in your local area or start
one yourself that it's a really valuable
tool to help you broaden your skill set
as well as keeping motivated because
being around other entrepreneurs there's
something about it that gets you
energized and excited another
opportunity to join or start an online
mastermind group and I have one that a
number of you guys are a part of and
what we do is meet up once a week and
it's a Facebook group people post
usually a video talking about what's
going on in their business what they
need help with we share a big win that's
happened we share what we need some
feedback on we share a resource that can
help the other entrepreneurs we set
goals for the next month and then
everybody submits replies and we try to
help each other out and I think being
able to surround yourself with those
kinds of people like-minded individuals
who have complementary skill sets who
can give you constructive feedback to
help you grow allows you to not create
in a vacuum and also makes me feel like
you're not alone in this
so my question of the day today for you
guys is I'm curious where you get
constructive feedback from do you have
family members who are entrepreneurs do
you have friends who are entrepreneurs
are you part of an online or in-person
mastermind group is something that your
you want to be a part of I'm really
curious where you get that feedback from
or maybe you're not getting enough of it
and you want more leave it in the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out thank you so much for watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
this prey so give me go